et c'est vraiment la vie en rose pour
marion cotillard qui a décroché tous les
prix pour son interprétation d'edith
piaf c'est une nouvelle carrière qui
démarre mais la comédienne a déjà à son
palmarès deux beaux succès sabine gorny
samuel guy bouffe la vie en rose
elle va la vivre elle a chanté en
anglais désormais grâce à pia c'était il
ya un an
lamotte sortait sur les écrans depuis
que du bonheur et des récompenses à tout
va de londres à paris en passant par los
angeles où elle commence sa carrière
américaine deux filons tournage avec
michael mann et rob marshall aux
commandes grâce à elle dit
marion est devenue la petite fiancée de
l'amérique
certains réalisateurs nulle envie de me
rencontrer et et c'est en ça aussi que
ça a changé ma vie des parents et des
frères comédiens une vraie fille la
balle mario une grande actrice reste est
toute simple
pas peu fier de présenter son film dans
un cinéma de village breton au bras de
sa grand mère
c'est super agréable ses copines et
copains du conservatoire d'orléans à la
cité des étoiles que de chemin parcouru
il écume embrasser de fait la jolie taxi
en dix ans marion enchaîné les films au
rythme de 2 à 3 par an film d'auteur
thriller comédie marion est une
boulimique hollywood va vite l'a
remarqué d'abord tim burton qui l'a fait
jouer dans big fish
trois ans plus tard quid les frottant
fait la partenaire de russell crowe une
carrière et un oscar qui suscite total
respect du cinéma français j'arrive bien
que
je trouve génial que la mairie tellement
qu'il a fait un parcours tellement
exemplaire
intéressant de la suivent de voir ce
qu'elle va faire mal est tellement belle
en plus elle est pure elle a une
luminosité qui comme ça émane d'elle une
gentillesse pour que les formidables
car m c'est génial ce ordinaire n'est
pas une actrice qui n'auraient vraiment
leur grosse tête
revivre ce qu'elle vient bientôt
d'autres lendemains qui chantent pour
marion à l'affiché d'une comédie
musicale aux côtés de sofia loren et
pénélope s'est excusé du feu hollywood
n'a pas fini de lui faire les yeux doux